once long ago in the deep blue below be
really grandmother everybody knows
there's no such thing as mermaids you
wouldn't say that if you didn't know
[Music]
this just came in I wanted to take
priority and we followed stories like
this before would witches working for me
that no not like this hundreds of
welcome to Mississippi
[Music]
there's a powerful magic in you a spirit
of the ocean let me introduce you to
your dreams The Little Mermaid of the
Mississippi
[Music]
she was so beautiful and I know she was
real
I'm skeptical
you shouldn't be here
[Music]
roommates
not
exist
[Music]
beautiful
so I have to go
Elizabeth
[Music]
he knows I made some
we have to save her
she's changing
[Music]
her soul is why
[Music]
I believe
[Music]
this zip is always been met
/ the moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
once long ago in the deep blue below
there's no such things were me you
wouldn't say that if you hadn't met well
this just came in it's actually from the
region and we followed stories like this
before but they never lead anywhere
maybe it's true maybe it's not but
that's definitely a story pack your bags
they're gone
this zip has always been magic for one
moment
this show does Harry there is some magic
that is real and some that is illusion
let me introduce you to your dream
the mermie Wow how do you have legs
where I come from we have a fairy tale
about a little girl born on land with
the heart of a movie she's real
that was tricked he took a part of me he
have it still there's no power greater
than my she can't leave without her soul
if she does she dies stay away from her
she doesn't belong to you I wonder that
you have
[Music]
besides I thought the underwater Kingdom
[Music]
I believe
[Music]
she said I had the heart of a Remy she
do
[Applause]
[Music]
you